a new development for Henderson as the
city is acquiring the Fiesta Henderson
site and plans to build a new Indoor
Sports facility located on East Lake
Mead Parkway it would be easy access for
downtown and Eastside residents this is
an exciting opportunity in our time for
the city of Henderson Jared Smith
director of Economic Development and
Tourism says it's not just local
families that would benefit from a space
like this he says the sports facility
could also bring in plenty of tourists
by hosting National tournaments and
traveling leagues as we decide what this
Center is going to look like and what
sports are going to be there we're going
to be actively engaging the community
and what types of facilities or what
types of amenities in these facilities
are you looking for that you feel would
be valuable and not just inside the
facility but for the remainder of the
property as well Michael hiltz of
Corcoran Global living commercial has
been a commercial broker in Henderson
for 25 years and says the growth is a
good sign of progress growth for city of
Henderson they need to have that to
sustain their low tax race and it's also
a plus for the residents to see a
building that now once was a casino and
then now became vacant and is now going
to be repurposed for another positive
use for the city of Henderson
neighboring businesses like Vegas Valley
Winery off Eastgate Road are only
minutes away from the property it's just
ready to to be something even better
than it was before marketing and events
director Nicole sharp says this move
will bring in more customers having a
sports complex that really caters to
families and to kids and really bringing
people not only from all around the Las
Vegas Valley but also bringing in
tourists from other states that come and
compete in sports leagues and you know
moms and dads want to drink beer and
wine so we're just right down the road
the purchase price comes at a hefty 32
million dollars and the City of
Henderson is set to complete the
Project's master plan in mid-2023 in
Henderson Mary Jean beliesza 8 News Now